[موسيقى]
هي السياسة في العالم هي جوليا
deschaumes أنا الخيارات والرئيس في
لديك حياة ريفية وتعطي يوتيوب لدينا
الحصان وساندرا هنا في المستوى
ورقة وتزعج حقا ووضعها هناك
لا ماوكلي
نشط في الصباح الباكر لدينا على استعداد
بالنسبة
ماذا ومن الناس
توزيع الباب في الوسط
كانت هذه العائلة من أفراد مشاة البحرية إلى
مشغول بحقول الزبدة
حلوة ومع ذلك تحصل على طابعك هناك
خط الكهرباء مؤلم وجيسي و
بنا أقل ذيلك وأصابع قدميك
بكى الهواء
الدولارات والنوافذ التي يمكن حتى
الأمن هناك الشتاء
مقصك وإذا قتل بالفعل و
الدعم النفسي والاجتماعي
لم افهم وهذا هو
شيء قاله أنه مزيد من الضغط
تحت شعبية لوكاس مرة أخرى في البداية دي
الاقتصاد حول الأرض
أعتقد والملك كوفى فريقي جيدًا جدًا
يمكن دائما الشحن
كلمات حلوة ثقيلة في
مكان العمل
رمز سيدي لديه مدرسة جديدة 5
عذرا القائمة حيث يوجد هنا أو هناك
نعم لا سيدي
مريض هنا ضد ابني دقيقة مثل
يقولون لربح الدعم الاجتماعي
كما سبق للأطفال
الذين السنة على استعداد لذلك في
عقليا الكثير من النشاط مع
المهنيين وكيف التخطيط الخاص بك
تقوية
القدرة على تربية موقع التعليم
الابن الصغير سيمونز الذي تخطط له 3
غادر مرة واحدة في المدرسة وبن الذي حرث
الشركة المحيطة بالمدرسة
هذه الفتاة القذرة في مفترق طرق العلبة
الفارس العادي هو قائمة جيدة
مينكا عبء ثقيل
بطريقتهم الخاصة هيرمان الحارة والناس
ولهذا أرى أن هذا هو
استجابة السكان والبيضاء الساحرة
سريع
قد يكون التضامن من إذا
عائلتك مجرد تأجيج
كيف هي اسبوع الاحتلال ورأينا ذلك
الرب الذي سيلنيوس من الناس
واحد هو تدريب المعلمين